[Musique]
oh
l'islande n'est qu'un ensemble de
volcans ils sont de toutes les formes de
toutes les tailles et ne ressemble en
rien à l'image d'épinal que tout le
monde s'en fait oublier le joli petit
cône parfait coiffé d'un panache de
fumée ici chaque relief a été façonné
par la lave et la cendre chaque montagne
abrite un géant qui a les pieds enfoncés
dans un magma profond
[Musique]
qu'ils soient si vaste qu'on ne puisse
les distinguer en entier qu'ils soient
cachés sous un glacier qu'il soit une
faille une colline une île les volcans
islandais lointain tiède et glacées sont
des foyers propice aux légendes et au
mythe
mais quand l'un d'eux entre en éruption
et bien toucher le reste du monde la
réalité fait surface et tous les yeux se
tournent vers ces colosses magique et
effrayant
[Musique]
le 14 avril 2010 le volcan
eyjafjallajökull entre dans une éruption
explosive qui va mettre l'islande sur le
devant de la scène médiatique
le nuage de cendres qu'il projette se
disperse au dessus de l'atlantique et de
l'europe
coupant un des réseaux aériens les plus
denses du monde
[Musique]
pendant six jours les aéroports
européens ferment leurs portes et les
compagnies aériennes perdent plus d'un
milliard d'euros la réaction en chaîne
est inévitable dans notre économie
moderne
le secteur touristique perd lui aussi
plus d'un milliard d'euros le kenya
détruit 400 tonnes de fleurs
la zambie ses légumes d'ouganda ces
poissons les composants électroniques
sont bloqués dans le monde entier
stoppant la production de plusieurs
milliers d'automobiles japonaises les
événements sportifs sont décalés faute
de participants et les dirigeants des
grands pays annulent leurs déplacements
[Musique]
au pied du volcan les chants des
fermiers islandais se recouvre
progressivement de l'épaisse couche de
sangles c'est tout à fait possible que
l'on soit forcé de mettre un terme à
l'agriculture et qu'il faille partir
s'installer ailleurs quitté les lieux de
mon enfance
les souvenirs personne ne sait vraiment
de quoi demain sera fait
quelques mois plus tard
l'eyjafjallajokull s'est apaisé les sens
autour de son cratère un lit de cendres
épais de plusieurs mètres qui recouvre
la glace et la neige
le monde entier pense avoir vécu un
événement volcanique majeure mais les
volcanologues islandais ne sont pas
dupes ils savent qu une énergie bien
plus considérables dort toujours sous
leur île
[Musique]
les éruptions volcaniques sont
évidemment très dangereuse
certaines peuvent menacer la vie et la
santé des halles eyjafjallajökull était
une petite éruption mais il ya d'autres
volcans ici pour lesquels on s'attend à
des éruptions beaucoup plus forte et ça
il ne faut surtout pas l'oublier
maintenant que le volcan s'endort
émettant quelques dernières volutes de
vapeur d'eau inoffensive
tout le monde voudrait savoir quel sera
le prochain à créer désordre et chaos
les volcans actifs d'islande s'aligne
sur le rift une ligne de séparation
entre deux continents
lille s'ouvre ainsi et grandit
continuellement elle se déchirant de se
fissurer craque
écartelé par une dérive imperceptible
[Musique]
à l'est l'europe et l'asie à l'ouest
l'amérique
deux plaques qui s'éloigne sans cesse et
dont le vide entre elles se comble par
des millions de tonnes de laves
basaltiques
mon
depuis des décennies géologue
sismologues physicien islandais ou
étrangers ont entendu sur ses terres un
réseau de surveillance
l'islande est progressivement devenu un
gigantesque laboratoire
tous les regards sont donc tournés
aujourd'hui vers ces scientifiques qui
étudient la moindre pierre la moindre
faille
les plus petits grincements et
gémissements de cette île minérale pall
einarsson oriente ses recherches depuis
40 ans sur les tremblements de terre la
croûte terrestre et les volcans il a
formé la plupart des géologues islandais
mais il continue de parcourir son pays
pour tenter de comprendre comment un tel
décor a pu se mettre en place
comment il peut changer
un des problèmes avec la volcanologie en
islande
c'est que nous n'avons pas un ou deux
volcans actifs
mais nous avons 30 volcan actif autour
du rift certains sont très difficiles à
cerner ce sont des bêtes très compliqué
qui demande de nombreuses mesures
comprendre ce qu'ils font comment
d'autres sont beaucoup plus simples et
plus faciles à comprendre ce que nous
savons sur nos volcan c'est qu'ils sont
tous différents
très différents les uns des autres nous
pouvons pas appliquer la même règle d'un
volcan à l'autre nous devons tous les
contrôles et c'est aussi simple que ça
nous devons donc étendre nos
observations sur l'ensemble du pays ce
qui nous demande énormément de travail
si jules verne avait trouvé en islande
sa porte d'entrée vers son voyage au
centre de la terre les volcanologues ont
découvert d'autres passages aujourd'hui
qui relie le coeur brûlant de lille au
monde extérieur
[Musique]
la plupart de nos volcan ne font rien
ils sont juste assis là certains
récupèrent de leur dernière invention
est restée calme
d'autres se préparent à un prochain
réveil ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ils sont
tous candidats pour la prochaine
éruption
s'ils sont tous candidats quatre d'entre
eux sortent du lot quatre volcans à haut
risque particulièrement surveillé
le volcan hekla selon la légende est une
porte d'entrée vers l'enfer la réalité
est qu'il entre en éruption brusquement
tous les dix ans la cia est un
gigantesque complexe volcanique au beau
milieu des hauts plateaux désertiques
il a déjà provoqué quelques unes des
plus puissante éruption du pays depuis
l'arrivée de l'homme en islande le
volcan katla enfermé sous la glace a
montré plus de 20 fois la puissance
qu'il contient dans son ventre
enfin au sommet de l'islande
le volcan grimsvoetn est enfermé lui
aussi sous une calotte glaciaire c'est
la demeure des géants et des trolls
c'est aussi le plus inaccessible de tous
[Musique]
je
l'islandais bjorn hotson est un
spécialiste des éruptions sous glaciaire
comme chaque année ils s'envolent vers
le lointain grimsvötn l'hélicoptère
reste le meilleur moyen pour monter sur
le plus grand glacier d'europe
grand comme la cance
[Musique]
les occasions sont rares de voler sur
cette chape givré où le froid et le vent
au règne sans compassion mais quand une
fenêtre s'ouvre elle révèle qu'au beau
milieu de ce désert immaculé le
grimsvotn a percé une couche de 200
mètres de glace
ces falaises sont les murs d'enceinte du
cratère la seule partie visible du
volcan géant
[Musique]
le dédale de rochers de glace repose sur
le point chaud de l'islande un passage
direct vers le centre de la terre vers
le manteau et son magma
les géologues comme bjorn haute-somme
commence à bien comprendre quelle est
cette bête qui somnole sous la glace
nous sommes ici au centre de la caldeira
placé au dessus du point chaud de
l'islande
le point chaud à ses racines dans le
manteau est ici le magma se laisse tout
droit jusqu'à la croûte terrestre
l'activité volcanique est donc très
forte dans cette zone comme un voyou
dans l'archipel a jailli directement on
peut en fait parler d'une double
activité parce que nous sommes aussi
entre deux continents entiers de l'océan
atlantique
donc le magma junte à la fois de la
séparation des continents mais aussi de
la présence du point chaud
c'est la raison principale qui fait le
volcan le plus actif d'islande il a
produit 70 éruptions depuis le
peuplement du pays en 874 l'activité
géothermique est elle aussi
particulièrement élevé il y à des spots
géothermique qui font fondre la glace
par en dessous et qui creusent ce qu'on
appelle des chaudrons visibles à la
surface du glacier
plus il ya de chaleur plus de chaudrons
et profonde
donc nous surveillons chaque année c'est
chou donne grâce aux radars et au gps
pour voir s'il s'approfondit
[Musique]
pour mesurer l'activité de ce volcan
caché il faut utiliser les moindres
manifestation lisible en surface la
chaleur prisonnière fait fondre la glace
et les eaux ruissellent au pied des
falaises elles s'accumulent au centre du
volcan dans sa caldera pour former un
immense lac aux eaux tièdes invisible
qui fait flotter le glacier comme une
banquise mesurer la hauteur du lac c'est
donc mesurer la stabilité de ce système
complexe et son comportement
ici au centre de laquelle des rats il
est difficile de joindre le monde
extérieur donc nous devons venir deux
fois par an pour récupérer les données
de la station
les mesures montrent que la pression
dont la chambre magmatique est proche de
celle de la dernière éruption
donc nous pouvons attendre une éruption
à tout moment l'éruption de 1983 a eu
lieu sous la falaise là bas en 2000 un
peu plus à droite et en 2004 dans le
coin là bas c'est éruptif se sont
déplacées de plus en plus vers l'ouest
donc je m'attendrais à voir la prochaine
éruption pour le coin nord-ouest de la
caldeira dès que tu trouves une loi dans
la nature elles changent
les cendres noires qui recouvre la glace
sont les témoins des précédentes
éruptions et les gigantesques chaudron
ceux d'une activité croissante
la plupart des volcanologues paris
aujourd'hui sur le volcan grimsvoetn
comme étant le prochain sur la liste des
éruptions islandaise au contact de l'eau
et de la glace
la lave va se fragmenter en minuscules
particules comme pendant l'éruption
d'eyjafjallajokull le panache on verra
dans les airs en mélange de vapeur d'eau
de bloquer de poussière de roche bourg
soufflées par les explosions vrai ato
magmatique
et les cendres fine pourront être
emportés par les vents dominants
[Musique]
si grimsvötn est le numéro un des
candidats à la prochaine éruption
il n'est pas pour autant le plus
inquiétant sa situation isolée ne menace
pas directement la population islandaise
la pression dans sa chambre magmatique
n'est généralement pas suffisante pour
que ces cendres puissent atteindre la
haute atmosphère
ces éruptions trop fréquentes ne lui
laisse pas le temps de se charger à
c'est alors si ce n'est pas sur le point
chaud que l'on trouvera aujourd'hui le
volcan le plus menaçant il faut suivre
la trace des scientifiques qui ont
installé dans chacun des sites sensibles
des camps de base des abris
[Musique]
nous sommes ici sur les contreforts du
volcan askia dont les cendres ont déjà
touché l'europe par le passé aujourd'hui
c'est un immense complexe volcanique au
milieu d'un désert de l'avs appelé le
désert des sacrifiés assoupie depuis 50
ans le volcan semble depuis peu vouloir
se réveiller nous allons simuler ici ce
qui se passe dans la chambre magmatique
d'un volcan pour comprendre comment se
déroule une éruption
nous avons ici un liquide représentant
le magma et du gaz dissous dans ce
liquide
c'est ce gaz qui est important car quand
ils se séparent du liquide décès choc
mais provoquent une éruption chez vous
donc là nous avons un mélange de gaz et
de liquides et quand tout à coup la
pression chute voici une chambre
magmatique en éruption la chambre
magmatique
c'est le coeur du volcan qui se vide où
se gonfle au long des éruptions
celui de la cia s'est vidée pour la
dernière fois en 1961
une fractures éruptives a laissé
s'échapper une longue coulée de lave
spectaculaire marquant la fin d'un cycle
[Musique]
la neige recouvre le paysage dix mois
dans l'année et les groupes
scientifiques du monde entier profite
des quelques jours d'été pour analyser
les battements discret qui rythment le
nouveau coeur du volcan et the dreamer
est anglaise et parcourt depuis plus de
20 ans les volcans actifs du monde à
travers son hutongs ouvert sur le coeur
des volcans
elle peut lire et quantifier les
changements de masse du sous sol qui se
produisent avant pendant et après une
éruption
ces outils sont des gravitent au m il
mesure avec précision les variations de
gravité la gravité dépend de la distance
avec le centre de la terre et ses
instruments sont tellement sensible que
si je mesure ici ou ici là où le sol est
un peu plus bas de quelques centimètres
je peux voir la différence ici je suis
plus près du centre de la terre donc la
gravité est un peu plus forte
ce que nous mesurons sont des variations
de gravité surtout le volcan et ce qui
m'intéresse ce sont les variations dans
le temps je fais donc ces mesures soient
les ans sur tous ces points et je
regarde comment ça évolue
la croûte terrestre est élastique et
réagit sur le volcan comme la croûte
d'un gâteau dont le coeur et fondant
sortie du four sorti d'une éruption
le soufflé retombe en se refroidissant
s'est dégonflé rapidement depuis 1961
c'est environ 6 cm parfait il est en
train de ralentir deux ou trois
centimètres par an
ce ralentissement peut-être que votre
corps ralenti avant de se gonfler un art
hogan et l'énorme quantité de magma qui
est sorti en 1961 a provoqué un
affaissement et le volcan a mis un
certain temps à se remettre de cette
élection c'est une longue phase un
retour
le ralentissement qu'on observe
aujourd'hui et j'ai une combinaison
entre leurs fins de cet affaissement
l'arrivée de nouveaux magma qui est en
train de s'accumuler sous astia ce que
nous pensons aujourd'hui
sous cette croûte brûler les normes
chambre magmatique se remplit à nouveau
sous la cia reste à savoir maintenant
quel type d'éruption le volcan préparent
chacun avec sa méthode complète celle du
voisin
le géologue suédois carl éric au lof
stoerkel partage sa vie entre l'islande
et l'université de göteborg
il se passionne pour les processus de dé
formation de la croûte terrestre
il sait qu'à ce kia est capable de
générer à l'avenir des éruptions
explosives colossal la pluie nous a
dérangé maintenant ce sont les
réflexions du soleil
on n'est jamais content c'est dur mais
je crois que je préfère souffrir du
soleil plutôt que de la pluie cette
coulée de lave en date de 1961 et après
cinq ans elle a arrêté de se contracter
de se refroidir
et ici ce n'est pas très épais
c'est nous mesurons l'inclinaison pour
voir s'il ya des changements dans la
chambre magmatique ligne qui va du
centre jusqu'à l'extérieur qui nous
permet de voir si ça monte ou 6 à 10 ans
la chambre magmatique fonctionne comme
un ballon et poussent sur les côtés
c'est juste une des nombreuses méthodes
pour suivre un volcan toutes ces
méthodes se complètent les unes les
autres
ce volcan entrera encore en éruption
il a déjà généré une des éruptions les
plus explosives de ces 150 dernières
années la même magnitude qu'en 1875
c'est très mauvais ce qui s'est passé en
1875 l'asca est entré en éruption au
printemps et à stockholm en suède
ils voyaient arriver de fines cendres
grises les gens marcher avec des
manteaux noirs de poussière et il
n'avait aucune idée d'où cela pouvait
venir
c'est seulement au bout de trois
semaines quand un bateau est arrivé
d'islande qu'ils ont su qu'une éruption
était encore ici ce type d'éruption
bloquera le trafic aérien détruira les
fermes et cetera et cetera
il s'agit là d'une éruption explosive
majeur
l'éruption de 1875 a été si puissante
qu'elle a provoqué l'effondrement d'une
grande partie du volcan aujourd'hui
remplie par un lac
ce lac est le plus profond d'islande
il s'enfonce à plus de 200 mètres en son
centre
s'il est possible de comprendre le passé
en lisant dans les lézardes des roches
dans la morphologie du paysage
il est beaucoup plus difficile de
prédire l'avenir avec précision tout le
monde aimerait savoir quand et comment
la sq ya pourra se réveiller certains
parlent d'une cinquantaine d'années
avant de le voir entrer en éruption à
nouveau
mais l'homme reste un nouveau né dans ce
monde qui avance et se transforme
lentement pendant des dizaines de
milliers d'années ou plus
hunt et beaucoup de choses se passent
pendant cette période
pour comprendre comment fonctionne un
volcan on doit faire des mesures aussi
longtemps que possible la vie d'un être
humain n'est rien à côté de celle d'un
volcan nous sommes pour quelques
décennies et nous n'avons qu'une vision
instantanée de ce qui se passe pendant
ces petits période de vie du volcan nous
n'avons aucune idée de l'évolution à
long terme du volcan je fais ces mesures
depuis 25 ans mes collègues islandais
sont là depuis bien plus longtemps
mais ce volcan était là bien bien
longtemps avant
des principales menaces liées aux
éruptions concerne le trafic aérien
c'est assez inquiétant qu'une les routes
les plus chargés passe juste au dessus
des volcans islandais
nous en parlons depuis longtemps et les
ja fret radio coutelas enfin montré que
le danger était sérieux
[Musique]
on ne peut pas s'étonner que les nuages
de cendres volcaniques viennent parfois
coupé une trajectoire
[Musique]
depuis le vol d'icare l'aviation civile
s'est largement transformé
[Musique]
le trafic aérien a complètement explosé
ces cinquante dernières années et le
monde entier se strient des incessants
voyages qui nous porte loin il vite
chaque seconde un avion commercial
l'école quelque part dans le monde
chaque jour on peut compter 80 mille
vols qui transportent des passagers
chaque année
ils sont 30 millions d'avion a sillonné
le ciel
[Musique]
le volcan hekla est un point nodal sur
ces routes aériennes
quand on travaille près du volcan il
peut voir un avion long-courrier passer
toutes les dix minutes juste au dessus
de son sommet et éclat est prêt à entrer
en éruption
on est passé très près d'un incident en
1981 un avion est passé juste au dessus
du volcan
quelques minutes avant qu'il n'entre
mary psion l'avion aurait pu être
descendu par deux ans je me suis dit en
le voyant que le pilote ne s'était sans
doute aperçu de rien tient d'habitude
les pilotes regarde plutôt de vente eux
que derrière le panache a coûté le
sillage juste derrière l'avion alors que
je travaillais au pied du volcan hekla
[Musique]
en islandais on parle du volcan hekla au
féminin son nom lui vient d'une petite
coquetterie sur le haut de la tête un
chapeau de nuages comme encapuchonnés
[Musique]
c'est pourtant l'un des quatre volcans à
haut risque inscrit sur la liste des
candidats pour la prochaine éruption
et quand les neiges ont fondu éclat
révèle son passé mouvement
[Musique]
éclat est imprévisible elle peut cracher
des nuages de cendres au dessus d'elle
comme faire couler de longue rivière de
lave chaude le long de ses flancs elle
est prête aujourd'hui à entrer dans une
nouvelle éruption
mais elle ne préviendra qu'au dernier
moment
non
son coeur de magma est trop profond pour
être vue des scientifiques
éclat et dangereusement surprenant
[Musique]
les fondent des scientifiques sont là
pour tenter de percer quelques-uns des
mystères cachés sous les tuniques
basaltiques de cette capricieuse pour
l'avoir souvent fréquenté bjorn la
connaît bien
passionné par la dynamique de cette
nature changeante
ici nous avons éclat et tout autour de
nous les champs de lave provenant des
différentes éruption durant ce siècle il
s'est réveillé en 1947 70 80 91 et 2000
on peut voir les différentes mouches sur
la lave qui nous montre les différents
âges la plus noire provient de
l'éruption de 2000 la règle et qui se
réveille tous les dix ans et dix années
ont passé depuis la dernière éruption
donc nous attendons une éruption d'éclat
très prochainement
la chambre magmatique est très profonde
à 50 kilomètres sous terre
donc il n'y a presque aucune secousse
qui nous prévient avant une éruption
[Musique]
au maximum sommes prévenus 30 minutes
avant que l'éruption de démarque en
jambes
c'est l'entrée vers l'enfant le roi doit
envoyer des gens ici en islande pour
espionner les islandais sur leur mode de
vie et les rapports indiquaient que
toutes sortes de créatures vivait dans
éclats et qu'un grand lac l'entouraient
crachant du feu pendant toute l'année
les gens avaient vraiment peur d'éclat
éclat n'est vraiment pas une montagne
comme les autres
[Musique]
il y à 250 avions par jour qui passe au
dessus de l'islande
il est donc certain que tôt ou tard les
volcans gêneront à nouveau le trafic
aérien
c'est une menace qui restera constante
tant qu'il y aura des avions
[Musique]
depuis les ja flatte l'oeil au couteau
les cellules de crise se sont organisés
pour mieux identifier les nuages de
cendres éviter la sur précaution et la
paralysie totale du trafic mais on le
sait la crise de l'eia fiat l' aider
liées à une éruption de faible amplitude
en cas d'éruption majeur plus longue
plus forte
les conséquences peuvent aller bien au
delà de la perte de quelques millions de
dollars
certains stigmates en islande font
ressurgir les drames de l'histoire
ils sont là pour rappeler jusqu'où peut
aller une éruption volcanique
[Musique]
où
l'éruption du volcan laki et dans la
mémoire de tous les islandais pourtant
les lave qui en sont sortis se sont
figés il y a plus de 200 ans
[Musique]
comme pour marquer le temps rien d'autre
qu'une mousse épaisse n'a poussé depuis
sur ces bus bon de roche
cette route verte indélébile a recouvert
600 kilomètres carrés de terre
l'équivalent de six fois la surface de
paris dix fois celle de l'île de
manhattan
[Musique]
toute cette lave a été vomi pendant huit
mois sans interruption par une fissure
parfaitement rectiligne la terre éclate
et donne naissance
aulaqi une chaîne unique de 130 cratères
[Musique]
le soufre le fluor le dioxyde de carbone
s'évapore de la roche en fusion et
recouvre tout le pays tuant la plus
grande partie des cheptels de moutons de
bétail et de chevaux
la longue période de famine qui suis tue
20 % de la population humaine islandaise
la faille béante s'ouvre sur 30 km c'est
la pire catastrophe naturelle survenue
en islande
[Musique]
les conséquences des volcans du laki se
sont envolés pour traverser les mers et
les continents les gaz et les cendres
ont envahit l'atmosphère jusqu en europe
et au delà
[Musique]
débrouillard acides ont gagné la norvège
l'allemagne la france l'angleterre tuant
indirectement des dizaines de milliers
de personnes
l'énergie du soleil ne pouvait plus
passer à travers ce filtre volcaniques
les saisons se sont déréglées pendant
des années
en france une succession d'événements
météorologiques à affamer les paysans
aux était trop doux se succédaient des
hivers trop rigoureux le gel pouvait
durer des semaines
des orages trou violents massacres et
les récoltes à force de grêlons nous
sommes en 1789 et le peuple français
meurent de faim en partie à cause d'un
volcan islandais
[Musique]
l'éruption d'eyjafjallajokull n'a fait
elle aucune victime
[Musique]
il sera toujours plus facile de garder
les avions au sol que d'arrêter les
grands bouleversements qui peuvent
suivre une éruption
maintenant que l'eyjafjallajokull s'est
rendormi il faut aussi prendre
conscience que la vie des hommes pourra
être directement toucher à l'avenir
[Musique]
malgré les conséquences spectaculaires
et la couverture médiatique sans
précédent qui a suivi nous sommes loin
de faire face à une éruption de grande
envergure
au contraire la cendre en quantité
raisonnable peut s'avérer être une
chance
[Musique]
à la fois des structures et fertile
c'est le paradoxe du volcan
et
[Musique]
au pied du volcan le décor s'est
complètement transformé les chants des
fermes sont en pleine renaissance
mon arrière grand père a vu l'éruption
de quatre là en 1918
mon grand-père celle de 1947 il venait
juste de prendre le relais de la ferme
comme aujourd'hui c'est ma première
année je connais le problème des cendres
l'éruption a commencé
nous avons dû abandonner la maison nous
sommes revenus le lendemain
et toutes étaient noirs et couverts de
sang varta vaches que c'était un show va
devoir son terrain et ses terres tout
noir en une nuit nous avons rapidement
penser à l'avenir
au moins et aux années qui allait suivre
mais nous avons décidé de prendre un
jour de ne pas prendre de grandes
décisions et de persévérer pour voir si
cela ne s'arrêterait pas et un jour sa
vie de six semaines
ça s'est arrêté alors nous avons attendu
de voir si l'herbe commencerait à
pousser ce qui est arrivé l'herbe a
réussi à pousser à travers la sambre
nous avons déjà fauché l'herbage deux
fois et nous allons bientôt le faire
pour la troisième fois
[Applaudissements]
éruption a eu lieu au meilleur moment
possible
juste avant que l'herbe ne commencent à
pousser en fait le timing est parfait
nous pensons que la cendre a un effet
isolant égard de la mer au chaud donc
l'herbe cracher vaccin n'avons pas
besoin d'utiliser autant d'encre à long
terme je pense que c'est bénéfique de
mélanger la cendre avec la terra nous
avons les récoltes dans les années à
venir devrait être meilleure veine
créative
la piste tout le monde attend maintenant
car la c4 en éruption
tout pourra redevenir noir d'état mais
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas peur de cas au
delà j'ai connu une éruption depuis mon
jardin je sais qu à sept kilomètres de
mon genre je ne crains pas la rater
4la est un volcan noyé sous la glace
4 la ccry taux féminin c'est la grande
soeur d'eyjafjallajokull
[Musique]
sa chambre magmatique est bien plus
volumineuse son glacier plus épais son
historique plus effrayant
les langues de cendres qui borde le
glacier repoussé par les fondent
successives sont là pour témoigner de la
violence des anciennes d'éruption katla
est prête pour un nouveau cycle tout le
monde le sait
[Musique]
à l'office météo de reykjavik emmanuel
pagneux tente de mesurer les risques
liés aux éruptions sous glacier la
dernière éruption de quatre places et
1918 et le panache de cendre était monté
à plus de 20 kilomètres d'altitude on
peut être 40 on n'est pas sûr parce qu'à
l'époque bien évidemment on n'avait pas
les instruments de mesure qu'on a
aujourd'hui
mais ce type d'éruption peut avoir un
impact sur le climat parce que le nuage
de cendres atteint la stratosphère ce
qui n'est pas le cas de l'eyjafjoll
hiatt donc les aérosols vont être mises
en circulation pendant plusieurs années
dans la haute atmosphère et est
contrarié en fait le rayonnement solaire
est peut-être induire donc un
refroidissement temporaire du climat
sous les séracs de glace un géant à
moitié endormi s'apprête donc à
perturber le monde personne ne peut dire
avec précision quand aura lieu
l'éruption
c'est une histoire de jours de mois ou
de quelques années
[Musique]
mais au delà des cendres projetées dans
l'atmosphère qui peuvent faire le tour
du monde
cat la menace aussi directement les
islandais qui vivent au pied de son
glacier
[Musique]
depuis des millénaires l'eau du glacier
fondu en porte les sambre la lave et la
roche pour descendre dans les vallées et
aplanir le paysage ces rivières
glaciaire chargé de tous les matériaux
volcaniques se transforme en véritable
raz-de-marée au cours des éruptions
elles construisent ainsi progressivement
d'immenses déserts de sable noir
[Musique]
l'islande s'agrandit constamment et
gagne sur l'océan
avant l'arrivée des premiers vikings
cette montagne était un îlot encerclé
par la mer
chaque fois que nous avons une éruption
sous la glace
eh bien il ya une grande quantité de
glace qui est fondu et qui va donner
lieu à des ondes de crues massive faite
d'un mélange d'eau de boue et de glace
pour l'éruption de l'eyjafjallajokul
même si les crues ont été importantes ça
n'est rien en comparaison
on est susceptible d'avoir ces quatre là
entre en éruption d'un volcan qui
beaucoup plus dangereux une ombre de
crue générée par une éruption du katla
d'après nos expertises pourraient avoir
une hauteur d'eau comprises entre 5 et
10 mètres
eva proximité du glacier plusieurs
dizaines de mètres c'est quelque chose
dont on a bien conscience en islande on
sait que cette région est
particulièrement exposée aux risques
volcaniques directs et indirects
mais cela n'est pas suffisant pour
convaincre ceux qui habitent dans la
région de quitter leur ferme et vision
toujours vécu de génération en
génération ce sont des fermiers des gens
qui sont très attachés à leur terre
j'habite ici mais je n'y pense pas trop
je sais bien que le volcan est là et oui
bien sûr je regarde de temps en temps
dans la direction du glacier
je sais que katla est là et cela ne
m'empêche pas d'aller où je veux à
n'importe quelle heure de la journée de
vivre sans y penser
katla est à sa place elle se réveillera
quand elle se réveille bien sûr c'est
terrible de penser à la végétation que
l'on a planté sur le désert de sa
imaginer que tout cela puisse redevenir
loire s'est produit je connais la terre
tellement bien imaginer les dégâts que
peut causer un lâcher d'eau sur ce
paysage vert ce n'est vraiment pas une
bonne chose
sans doute moins dangereux de vivre ici
pas de quatre là que dans les rues de
reykjavik
nous vivons sur une terre volcanique et
nous devons apprendre à vivre avec son
volcan
nous ne pouvons pas faire autrement nous
devons les étudier et savoir ce qu'ils
nous préparent ils sont ici et nous
sommes ici nous devons en tirer le
meilleur parti ils présentent certains
avantages
nous obtenons l'eau chaude de la terre
grâce au volcanisme
c'est notre pétrole c'est une source
d'énergie que nous utilisons de manière
intensive quelque chose que nous devons
jamais oublier c'est que sans les
volcans il n'y aurait pas dit ça
l'islande est entièrement faite de
volcans
en islande la géologie est visible pour
tout le monde ici on peut voir les
choses avant qu'elles n'arrivent
nous avons les tremblements de terre qui
nous tiennent en éveille en nous ce
courant régulièrement des volcan entre
en éruption tous les deux trois ou
quatre ans et il suscite un énorme
intérêt chez les islandais
c'est un des divertissements les plus
populaires donc à la moindre petite
éruption
les gens se déplacent en grand nombre
pour les observer et se laisser
impressionner
[Musique]
c'est une expérience très
impressionnante de voir une éruption
le plus séduisant en islande n'est pas
que ses habitants vivent au milieu des
chaudron bouillonnant d'une terre prête
à exploser à se fendre en deux le plus
séduisant en islande et que les
islandais ne peuvent pas se passer du
spectacle de cette nature il n'ya alors
rien d'étonnant à ce que les islandais
soient les plus grands admirateurs de
feu d'artifice au monde
[Musique]
où
vous
[Musique]